LAWRENCE: s A 20 MIDTERM
ELECTION DRAW CLOSER BIGGEST
FACTOR IN WHO CONTROLS WON'T BE
A FLASHY AMERICAN TV AD IT'S
AMERICAN PEEMG AND I'VE BEEN
TALKING TO AMERICANS FROM ALL
DIFFERENT WALKS IT HAVE LIFE
I'VE HEARD FROM IN THES,
REPUBLICANS, INDEPENDENTS
LIBERTARIANS YOU NAME IT WHAT
BETTER WAY TO TAKE PULSE OF OUR
NATION THAN BY BRINGING PEOPLE
TOGETHER FROM ALL OVER THE
POLITICAL SPECTRUM AND ASKING
THEM HARD HITTING QUESTIONS AND
WHAT MATTERS IN THEIR SHRIEVES I
DID THAT WITH A GROUP OF VOTERS
IN TOLEDO, OHIO AND FOUND OUT
WHAT MATTERS MOST TO THEM AHEAD
OF ELECTION DAY.
WATCH.
YOU GUYS ARE SWING STATE.
YOU GUYS ARE GOING DECIDE A LOT
IN THE NEXT ELECTION.
I WANT TO GO IF YOU FIRST WHAT
IS THE BIGGEST ISSUE FACING YOU
AND YOUR FAMILY?
>> I FAIL TO SEE HOW IT CAN BE
ANYTHING OTHER THAN THE ECONOMY
OF ABSOLUTELY EVERY ONE I SAW
PEOPLE PUTTING GROCERIES BACK ON
SHELVES IT IS ABSOLUTELY
HEARTBREAKING.
>> WHAT'S THE TYPE OF ISSUE FOR
YOU?
>> I THINK INFLATION AT THE
BUSINESS THAT I'M IN BETWEEN
THAT AND SUPPLY CHAINS, YOU KNOW
EVERYTHING THAT WE'RE PURCHASING
WITH ANY KIND OF MARKET, BEEF
MARKET POULTRY MARKET, ANYTHING
WITH OIL --
IS JUST ASTRONOMICAL PAYING TWO
AND A HALF TIME WHAT IS WE WERE
PAYING TWO, THREE YEARS A.
>> BIGGEST THING IS WITH THE
RIGHT IF TO ABORTION IS NOT JUST
TO THE GOVERNMENT INTRUDING IN
MY HEALTH CARE SITUATIONS BUT
THAT OPENS GATE QEA WAY TO
DECIDE WHAT BIRTH CONTROL PEOPLE
CAN AND CANNOT USE AND EVEN IF
SOMEONE CHOOSES TO MARRY.
>> AS EDUCATION PROFESSIONAL,
OBVIOUSLY, THERE'S HOT ISSUES ON
THE SEAT FOR THE EDUCATION
REALM.
AND JUST THE IMPORTANCE OF THOSE
ISSUES FOR ME ARE --
STRAIGHT FROM MY HEART.
EDUCATION IS ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT YOU CAN'T ON THAT IT HAS TO
BE IN THE FORE FRONT BECAUSE
EDUCATING OUR CHILDREN IS THE
FUTURE.
>> THE ECONOMY HANDLE DOWN LET'S
LOOK AT IT THE STOCK MARKET IS
DOWN ALMOST 25% EVERYONE
PORTFOLIOS ARE DOWN IT IS
UNACCEPTABLE A LOT OF PEOPLE
NEED TO RETIRE, AND IT'S JUST
NOT SUSTAINABLE.
>> THE ECONOMY, I MEAN, IT'S
ALWAYS BIGGEST ISSUE FOR ME AS A
VOTER IT IS THIS TIME TOO.
NOBODY LIKES PAYING HIGHER
PRICES SO THIS MATTERS TO
EVERYBODY.
BUT --
WE ALSO GOT TO MAKE SURE
WHATEVER ECONOMIC POLICY WE TAKE
TO CONTROL INFLATION DOESN'T
HARM --
HARM AS LITTLE PEOPLE AS
POSSIBLE.
WE KNOW POLITICAL DEBATE OF RED
STATES NOW SENDING SMFLT LEGAL
MIGRANTS TO DEMOCRAT CITIES.
SO THIS IS ONE OF THE TOP ISSUES
THAT'S GOING TO BE FACING NEXT
ELECTION.
SO WHO HANDLING ISSUE OF
IMMIGRATION, THE BEST I'LL MIX
IT A LITTLE BIT.
I HAVE TO START WITH YOU.
REPUBLICANS ALL RIGHT MAC.
>> DEMOCRATS.
SALLY --
>> REPUBLICANS.
>> LAURI DEMOCRAT, NEITHER --
>> NEITHER.
OKAY.
TONY WHY DID YOU SAY NEITHER?
>> NO ONE HAS PUT FORWARD A GOOD
PLAN TO HELP IMMIGRATION.
I THINK REPUBLICANS ARE DEFINITE
MAKING IT WORSE SO WHO IS DING A
BETTER JOB IT IS DEMOCRATS BUT I
DON'T THINK DEMOCRATS ARE DOING
AN ADEQUATE JOB THEY SAY THEY
CARE ABOUT IT.
BUT --
YOU SEE SITUATIONS THAT WE HAVE
GOING ACROSS THE COUNTRY WITH
IMMIGRATION DECADES NOW TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT IT AND NO ONE
HAS DONE ANYTHING SO DEMOCRATS
SAY THEY WANT TO HELP.
BUT THEY HAVEN'T AND
REPUBLICANS, I MEAN, THEY'RE
STRAIGHTFORWARD THEY WANT TO
MAKE IT WORSE AND THEY DO.
YEAH.
THAT'S MY FEELING ON IT.
>> HAS TOPIC OF IMMIGRATION
BECOME A POLITICAL FOOTBALL?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
YEAH.
ABSOLUTELY.
>> 100%.
>> I DIDN'T KNOW I THINK I WOULD
AGREE ON BASIS POINT THAT
GENTLEMEN SAID THIS IS ABOUT
HUMAN LIVES.
AND IF YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
HUMAN LIVES, MORE MIGRANTS HAVE
DIED TRYING TO ILLEGALLY CROSS
BORDER THAN THEY DID UNDER TRUMP
ADMINISTERING.
POLICIES OF THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION MIGHT NOT LIKE
THEM BUT THEY SAVE LIVES SO IF
YOU CARE ABOUT SAVING LIVES
REPUBLICANS HANDLE IT BETTER
THAN IN THES WHAT WE HAVE SEEN
NOW ISN'T GOOD FOR ANYONE.
IT IS NOT GOOD FOR THE COUNTRY
AND IT IS DEFINITELY NOT GOD TO
INVITE PEOPLE HERE WOMEN AND
CHILDREN THEY ARE ABUSED, SUFFER
AND YOU'RE RIGHT BECAUSE OF
POLITICS THAT WERE INVOLVED THE
BLUE CHECK MARKS ON TWITTER NO
LONGER CARE ABOUT THESE PEOPLE
THEY'LL CARE IF IT IS A
REPUBLICAN PRESIDENT AND THAT IS
ABSOLUTELY DISGRACEFUL.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK IS DRIVING
ALL OF THIS CRIME ACROSS THE
COUNTRY?
>> WELL, I MEAN TBB YOU THINK
ABOUT IT INFLATION IS GOING UP.
SOFT CRIME POLICIES, I MEAN,
WITH THE WAY THE SITUATION IS,
PREEM FORCED TO MAKE CERTAIN
DECISIONS AND WHEN THERE'S NO
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THESE
ACTIONS, PREEM MORE LIKELY TO
JUST COMMIT THEM.
>> WHEN IT COME FROM TOP
ADMINISTRATION FROM PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES AND YOUR VICE
PRESIDENT KAMALA HARRIS
CRIMINALS ARE GOING TO SEE THAT.
OF COURSE, WHEN YOU SEE CHAOS IN
BLUE STATES OF THE --
DEMOCRAT GOVERNORS AND STUFF NOT
CONTROLLING THEIR CITIES NOT
CONTROLLING THEIR STATE.
IT'S --
, OF COURSE, THEY'RE GOING TO DO
IT AND WHEN THEY SAY WE'RE GOING
LET YOU GO, EVERYBODY WILL SAY
THAT AND BE OKAY WITH IT.
UNTIL IT COMES TO YOUR FRONT
DOOR AND WHEN IT COMES TO YOUR
FRONT DOOR YOU'RE LIKE THEY NEED
TO BE ARRESTED REPEAT OFFENDERS
HE'S IN MY YARD WHEN YOU'RE
SCARED OF THAT, THAT'S WHEN YOU
TAKE A STANCE OF I DON'T LIKE
THIS ANYMORE.
THIS HAS COME TO MY HOME, MY
CITY, AND IT'S --
ABSOLUTELY OUT OF CONTROL.
>> BUT I GUESS WHEN YOU LOOK AT
THE CLIMATE RIGHT NOW, AND THE
CRIME GOING UP ALL ACROSS THE
COUNTRY, DID --
DID THE ADVOCATES TAKE IT TOO
FAR OR WERE THERE JUST A LOT OF
VOICES THAT WERE REALLY SMALL
VOICES THAT SAID LISTEN WE WANT
TO EMPTY SOME OF THE JAILS --
WHERE DO YOU FALL ON THAT IN IS
THERE A BALANCE THERE?
>> A HUGE GENERATION AND WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT LIKE EXTREMELY
COMPLICATED SUBJECT AS FAR AS
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM GOES YOU
KNOW, WE NEED TO --
WE NEED TO DO EVERYTHING WE CAN
TO PREVENT VIOLENT CRIME AND
LOCK VIOLENT CRIMINALS UP AND
NONVIOLENT PEOPLE THERE NEEDS TO
BE A PATH TO REHABILITATION AND
WHEN THEY DO CONTINUOUSLY, YOU
KNOW, BREAK THAT, THEN THAT'S
WHEN I AM FOR HARSHER SENSING.
LAURI IF YOU HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SHAPE AND MOLD A
CANDIDATE, WHAT WOULD THAT
CANDIDATE LOOK LIKE?
WHAT WOULD BE THE VALUE SYSTEM
OF THAT CANDIDATE?
>> THEY NEED TO UNDERSTAND THE
NEEDS OF THE COMMUNITIES AND
RESPECT ALL PEOPLE WITHIN THAT
COMMUNITY AND WANT TO REACH OUT
AND LIFT EVERYONE UP AND MAKE
SURE THAT EVERYONE HAS
RESOURCES.
>> YEAH, DAVID.
>> I WOULD SAY A CANDIDATE WHO
HAS THE ABILITY TO MEET PEOPLE
WHERE THEY ARE.
SOMEONE WHO HAS THE ABILITY TO I
THINK --
HAS ABILITY TO COMPROMISE.
I THINK THAT'S SOMETHING THAT'S
COMPROMISE IS ACTUALLY SEEN AS
WEAKNESS BETWEEN VOTERS ATTEND A
LOT OF AMERICANS AND --
I THINK IT'S NO SECRET THAT, YOU
KNOW, WE'RE PROBABLY AS DIVIDE
AS WE'VE BEEN PROBABLY SINGS THE
1850s.
AND SO TO ME I WOULD WANT
SOMEBODY ABLE TO MEET SOMEBODY
WHERE THEY ARE AND SAY I MAY
DISAGREE WITH YOU BUT THIS IS
COMMON GROUND TO MEETS ON AND I
THINK MORE POLITICIANS HAD THAT
ATTITUDE WE CAN GET A LOT MORE
DONE IN THIS COUNTRY.
COMMON GROUND THAT'S NOT A WORD
I'VE HEARD --
[LAUGHTER]
IN N